[Music]
hello and welcome to this episode of
dear Hank and John it's go potty
oh sorry I forgot about you John usually
I get to come in there what what did you
want to say forget it it's a comedy
podcast about death work me and my
brother John we answer your questions
give you DB suffice to bring you all the
week's news for both bombers and AFC
Wimbledon how you doing John I mean I
was doing all right until I didn't get
to say my line now I feel like I've been
left out I feel like I got picked last
on the playground actually you know what
hick it's not so much a question of how
I'm doing it's a question of how I'm
smelling and the answer is fantastic and
do you want to know why oh oh sure yes
it's because I've acquired a new sponsor
Hank did you get 378 of something so I
you may remember that I got 378 Snickers
bars after telling the nice folks at
Mars that I love their work at VidCon
Anaheim mm-hmm I'm no dummy
so when we went to VidCon Europe Hank I
sought out all of the sponsors whose
products I enjoy and I was sure to let
them know about it
you serious see this happened again I'm
gonna be am I gonna be really mad
including lush what the the makers of
fine bath balls I think I don't know if
you know this about me but I am a math
person I don't take showers I think
showers are just terrible it's a form of
assault
you're basically agreeing to be
assaulted by droplets of water coming at
you at a high rate of speed they're kind
of like slow water bullets is how I
think of showers okay so and so I'm a
bath taker and I've always loved
luscious bath balls and I'm not just
saying that because they're not my
personal sponsor but I was so I met the
people from lush and I was like
obviously I love your work you know it's
cruelty-free it's organic it's great you
make some wonderful soaps and shampoos
all kinds of stuff I love it and sure
enough four days later what shows up at
my office but a metric crap ton of bath
balls
okay John I okay okay so first of all
that's yeah I I am happy for you I don't
know why I'm so excited I've already had
two bath ball baths and they're
wonderful but I do have I do have two
things to say first of all I have
received from not sponsors but fans of
the pod two different in 378 I have
received three hundred seventy eight
pennies from some Nair - well who can go
yeah find a hole to crawl inside of and
be ashamed of themselves but I have also
received and my office has been very
pleased or certain members of them from
a bunch of fans of the pod three hundred
and seventy eight of a a snack
candy snack thing from Philadelphia
called orion's and they are quote Irish
potatoes which is a weird thing to say
because potatoes are kind of already
Irish potatoes but they are they're
they're kind of like a coconut ball
dusted with cinnamon and they are not my
bag but lots of people in my office like
them so we've got them up and done and
they're getting gone through pretty
quick so I am I did receive that
sponsorship from Orion's even though
Orion's didn't pay for it so if you live
in Philadelphia and you want to try
something that's the mostly coconut
checkout o Ryan's Irish potatoes they're
candy question mark Hank you know I
don't like to be pedantic but I would
just like to point out that potatoes are
not Irish potatoes are a new world food
that only came to Ireland after the
Columbian Exchange I know but they were
very important in the history of Ireland
we think about potatoes as an Irish
thing just like we think about potatoes
as an Idaho thing even though they're
also not from Idaho I think they
actually might be from Idaho they're not
they're from South America only South
America didn't they travel north I mean
they have now be potatoes already where
does anything from in the end point
being Hank lush makes wonderful bath
balls and I've just learned as a result
of this gift basket that I was given
also excellent soap
uh-uh that's that's wonderful you know I
know that we're still talking about this
and that it's been 10 minutes of
fighting already it hasn't but yep I
also I did I did do the thing I tried to
do the thing and I reached out to [ __ ]
on Twitter the makers of the Pocky
candies and and they got in touch with
me and they sent me a Pocky gift basket
but I feel like it didn't quite count
because I was expecting 378 boxes of
Pocky and what I got was maybe 378
individual Pocky sticks if I didn't
really count but that does that doesn't
seem like it to me cuz it's like it's
like saying like oh I got you rice
sponsored your podcast with 378
individual grains of rice that's well
Hank here's the thing I I mean you're
good at a lot of stuff obviously like
you're really good at planning and
executing vidcon's which I personally
appreciate because it allows me to have
sponsors but what you're not good at is
talking to corporations and corporate
representatives in a way that makes them
want to send you free stuff and like
that's why there's two of us we have you
to organize the conferences and and run
the businesses and all that boring stuff
and then we have me to it to look dead
into the eyes of the person who runs
lucious marketing and say I love your
bath balls and to say it so sincerely
that they cannot help but send me
amazing high-quality a number one bath
balls by the way it came in it was a
huge variety of bath balls too and I'm
just having the best time
god I mean I don't can you can you
explain to me before we get to questions
from our listeners really quickly why
anyone who has the choice to take a bath
would ever take a shower I have the
choice and I take maybe a bath a year
maybe oh my god oh my god like you could
have a relaxing quiet you focused
experience or you could have these water
bullets attack you John I don't have
time to have a relaxing quiet me focused
experience and if I'm gonna have one
it's gonna be me alone in my office
working which I enjoy quite a lot better
you I feel bad I feel bad for people who
think they don't have time for baths
because if you don't have time for a
bath what do you have time for nothing
in the end if you're not taking care of
yourself you're not taking care of
anybody taking care of myself I'm taking
nice relaxing baths in logistics John
I'm alright let's get to some questions
from our listeners Hank alright Emmy who
asks dear brothers green my name is Emmy
that happened again and well this
problem will probably not be an issue
for me for a few years yet it's
bothering me I have this intense desire
to see the world from Thailand to Machu
Picchu to Paris at the same time I care
deeply about the environment I know the
traveling it has a lot of significant
effects on the environment so how do I
keep my carbon footprint low while
seeing this big world is it even
possible penguins and pollution Emme
it's not really possible it's not really
possible ah no I mean I guess you could
get really good at rowing there are some
people who like row across the Pacific
Ocean sailboats just get a sailboat just
get power that wait I mean I feel like
there's a lot of carbon that goes into
the building of a sailboat where do you
get like a little kayak and you just you
just row that guy across the ocean you
could see most of the world that way
most of the cool parts are connected to
the oceans I can say that because of
course I live in Indiana I mean the
problem is that there is a lot of ocean
that is not connected to cool parts it
is just connected to other ocean that's
a great point Hank that's a great
observation I've actually never I've
actually never been more than about
three miles off shore so but a casual
glance at Google Earth does confirm some
of those concerns yeah I mean I once so
I I have the same problem I once
investigated whether or not I could just
like hitch a ride on like a barge that
was already carrying a bunch of stuff
because like of course Bart barges are
always going across the ocean and they
and you can
book passage on a barge and you can stay
on the barge along with the barge crew
who makes the barge real function yes
and you can get like a cabin and it's
pretty miserable and slow and it takes
it takes a long time and it is not a
nice experience but I it also and also
additionally you get that that like not
great experience and it is more
expensive than flying I don't know why
but maybe because there is like a
certain type of person who does this and
they are people who hate planes but also
really need to get to Europe a couple
times a year and don't mind spending a
month doing it so don't try that one oh
you could do that at me so there you go
if you have a ton of money and also a
ton of time and also a desire to hang
out on a container ship now we've got
your passage to Europe it's done it's
done you can always buy carbon you can
always buy carbon offsets and those do
function it feels a little bit like
cheating to me but you but that you know
that is that you know the people who use
carbon offsets to do good things they
rely on people to buy carbon offsets in
order to do those good things whether
that's protecting forest land in South
America or planting trees here or you
know making wind power or solar power or
less expensive in America so carbon
offsets are always the thing that's
available but but you will always there
is no way to get around the world
without pumping out that co2 I will say
that purpose in germ Isle 747 is not
that inefficient it's just that there's
a lot of miles that go into
international travel right I mean but
this this goes back to something we've
talked about a number of times on the
pot Hank which is that there is always
going to be attention in contemporary
life between values and lived experience
and I do not know I have no solution for
that problem it it is complex and I mean
the more the more you look at it the
more you realize wow I sure do like you
know like live in
dror de neri luxury while people die and
there's no yeah no I mean you could
probably spend all of your resources on
malaria and it would be a better use of
your resources than probably whenever
I'm lying except for of course lush
cosmetics which are quasi free and
everybody everybody involved in the
company is paid a living wage let's move
on to another question from our
listeners I am such a good advertiser
Hank I'm just I'm just trying to can you
imagine if diet dr. pepper it had the
good sense to get on board with me I
mean God their business instead they're
relying on this this prince like a
spokesperson called a lil sweet this is
one of the strangest marketing campaigns
I've ever seen and also one of the least
effective this question comes from
Natalie Dear John and Hank my friend and
I recently had a heated discussion about
whether or not Batman is a superhero Oh
No why did you highlight this question
we've already had this discussion you've
experienced the wrath of Batman fans
John so you'll know that they defend him
to the death however I would argue that
he isn't a superhero I say this because
to me a superhero is a hero who has
superhuman abilities excellent point
Natalie I think super heroes don't exist
outside of comic books so does a
superhero have to be able to do things
other humans physically never could like
fly or possess super strength etc can
they be people who just have great ABS
and some cool technology Batman's a hero
for sure she said dubiously I just don't
think he's super shark repellant and
sidekicks
Natalie great question I would argue
that Batman is not a superhero and
furthermore that Batman is not a
particularly impressive member of the
Justice League I also I want to argue
that Batman also does not exist outside
of comic books so just like first things
first take care of that point makes it
sound like Batman's real not actually
but there is it there is definition of
superhero both in Wikipedia and whatever
Google is parsing it says a benevolent
fictional character with super
and powers such as Supriya so you're
right Batman is not not a superhero at
least according to the definition that
popped up first when I googled what it
yeah and you can tell that Hank has been
a lot of time researching the question
as well um I I don't think I don't think
Batman's a superhero I also just
searched oh I can't eat while I
understand that I got a lot about Batman
wrong when I in my video where I
criticized Batman I still think you want
to talk about like effective use of
resources I still don't think Batman is
using his resources particularly
effectively now I'm happy to admit that
I am not either right like if I were
into distributing resources efficiently
toward altruistic ends I probably would
not sponsor AFC Wimbledon but I also
don't expect to have like comic books
written about me and what a great guy I
am and that's that that's the thing
that's always bothered me about Batman
is that like in a way Batman is like a
celebration of a billionaire mostly for
being a billionaire it is a weird thing
and and and I think you know
I feel ya I feel ya I think that we're
both right on the Batman issue John I
think that you could like that there can
be nuanced position is that that seemed
initially contradictory but are in fact
in agreement and that is how I feel
about our Batman debate I think we have
really come to a place where it makes a
lot of sense and and we understand
Batman in a fuller way than previously
could have been possible without the
song of fication by the Gregory Brothers
which every argument deserves now I
agree they've done they're amazing
they're they're my favorite brothers on
YouTube and that's really saying
something this is another question if it
comes from Vienna who asks dear green
brothers if hypothetically I took a boat
out into the ocean and discovered a
hitherto unknown Island what steps would
I have to take to claim it as my own is
it enough to just land there and set up
a colony in the great British tradition
do I have to have some kind of military
to defend it please respond as I feel it
important to have a plan for this
contingency pimento quarry
Vienna I didn't get that until I said it
out loud I mean I've got good news and
bad news for Vienna and the bad news is
that there are no hitherto unknown
Iowans and based on the trend in sea
levels none will be appearing anytime
soon I mean the government of China
would disagree with you they seem to be
very good at discovering hitherto
unknown islands and said it's true Terry
bases on them that's true they're doing
a great job with their dredges at
building new islands and if Vienna is in
possession of a extremely large scale
industrial economy that will allow
Vienna
to build islands out of the ocean ala
the South China Sea or or what's
happening in the Persian Gulf then
that's great but if not this is
irrelevant if so it seems like in order
to claim an island as your own mostly
you have to convince the international
community that that island is your own
and you need to get them to acknowledge
it which is something that China has
kind of struggled to do well you know
they're still they're still working on
it now John it's possible that Vienna
does have you know a fairly large
industrial economy is Vienna the city of
Vienna I would argue even if so which is
it's possible that the city of Vienna
wrote in to our podcast to check on the
sitch with regards to colonizing
hitherto unknown islands it's unlikely
but it's possible I would argue that the
city of Vienna but based on the one day
that I've spent there is not really in a
position to be building new islands they
have a lot of history to take care of
just in their city and as I recall
Vienna is not on an ocean no in fact it
is in a country that does not have any
access to an ocean or even a sea there's
a ladder excess I think they I think you
can
get there via the river Danube in an
emergent but it takes it takes a minute
my guess is that if you got in the river
Danube you would eventually reach the
sea correct yeah Hank and I are experts
in geography as you can likely tell I am
following the Danube down to the ocean
right now wait back up back up back up
there is an island there is a huge
island on the river Danube great we're
in via in Vienna like downtown Vienna
based on this Google map search that I'm
doing right now is essentially divided
by an island let me see if there's
people on it I see it yeah it's a nice
looking Island it's got oh it's a
beautiful park it looks like it's mostly
just parkland I don't Vienna I don't
think you're gonna have trouble claiming
this park as your own especially since
there's a there's a festival it seems to
be some kind of music festival in it
called rock in Vienna so just the
language of that would make me think
that that's yours so I think you're good
on this one River Island I don't know if
you'd be good on like oh yeah this river
is nice-looking Island it seems to be
that Vienna has already claimed this
river island it seems that this River
Island is very clearly already Vienna's
so Vienna just you've got it right now I
kind of I mean if this makes me actually
want to go back to Vienna so that I can
go for a jog on this massive and
beautiful river island River Island it
looks very nice and no uh yeah it's a
completely understand kits like Central
Park but in the middle of the river and
bigger than Central Park oh well I mean
have we have we settled that one or what
I mean we really we nailed it it has a
beach even for families with in
parentheses small children the 250 meter
long family Beach offers safe and
child-friendly bathing fun why do your
children out to be small what if I my
children are like what about my my grown
children 45 and 32 no what if I want to
bring my like medium sized
seven-year-old child do I have to is
there like you if you are taller than
this you can't visit the family beach
thing
okay this place is actually called
danube island and according to the
government of Austria which admittedly
does have a dog in the fight
it is a recreational paradise but one
thing it has the world's biggest
trampoline center at the Danube jumping
complex in the immediate vicinity of the
Wrights Brook young and old jumped
closer to the sky and all in front of
Vienna's wonderful skyline we're talking
about the world's biggest floating
trampoline center with 40 individual
jumping areas
trampolining is a unique combination of
sport and fun the adults should also
have a go hold on is it outdoor I love
it
I can't wait to go to I cannot wait to
go to the Danube Island this place looks
amazing it's an it's an outdoor
trampoline Center they also have a they
also have one of those like high ropes
courses where you learn teamwork I mean
of course because the Austrians they
love teamwork also this this rock
festival that is going on in the Google
Maps version that we're looking at right
now you can camp on the island there's a
bunch of camping happening and I think
I'll stay in one of Vienna's stately old
hotels and just visit the island during
the day but yes I understand that
there's a lot of opportunities point
being what Hank and I really need is not
like sponsorship from another
corporation what we really need is visas
to almost any European country that will
just allow us to stay there and get that
sweet sweet health care and contribute
meaningfully to society well I mean yes
that is that kind of brand deal like is
that a brand deal that's available like
instead of getting my god you know for a
brand deal Snickers bar is it's just
like you come live and get free health
care in our like you now it's like the V
Slyke the brand deal visa and
immigration it brand deal yes
you're basically you're agreeing to cast
your personal brand with Australia or
New Zealand or Austria or whomever it is
that comes up and
makes that makes the deal that would be
the best brand deal ever and I came to
you and they were like listen if you
live in Australia for the next 20 years
we will give you that sweet sweet free
health care and in addition maybe like a
stipend a spa this is like a department
like hair here maybe on Danny violent
get me an apartment on Danube Island I'm
the only person who lives there yes and
then I then I just like go around
Austria and I'm like you should vacation
in Austria Austria it's beautiful
mountainous I know about this place
there's salt mines are there salt ones
for some reason that's the thing I know
about Austria yes there they're thinking
this place called Salzburg is that right
and they do have soldiers there was salt
there I so during the one day that I
spent in Vienna of course all I did was
go to the catacombs where there's like
thousands of dead bodies underneath the
churches and I walked around more so
like tunnels have and saw the like
thousands of skulls and everything and I
was very impressed it was it was one of
the better catacombs that I've ever seen
and I definitely emerged from that
catacomb experience thinking that could
live here all right well they seem to
have Alps they seem to have a good
number of Alps in Austria it just looks
like a real nice place all right so we
figured it out as long as as long as it
comes with that health care I'm sorry
what was the question
Vienna you already have an island Oh God
my god we have travelled a far distance
from the original question let's let's
move on let's let's recenter ourselves
Hank with another question fog this one
comes from David who writes dear john
and hank i live in Tooting south london
my god can't we just stop the question
for a second and i realize we have not
answered a lot of questions today but
that's not really a place is it
it's Tooting to rosianna is there really
a place called Tooting in England there
is
there's also Tooting Bec she says this
is how can a country with like 18 people
have so many place names anyway I live
in Tooting South London not far from
Wimbledon yay team I recently discovered
that there is a Langston Hughes closed
in Brixton which I thought you'd be
pleased to learn and I am although I
don't know what it closes you already
have a fictional space in nerdfighteria
but would you like to have a real-life
Road named after you where would it be
what would be on it and what would you
go with Street Avenue Road close I guess
closes a kind of road lane or way
acknowledging that even this attempt at
immortality would decay in time David
thank you for the acknowledgement David
would speak like Hank Road is that the
idea or it would be like I assumed it
would be like I assumed it would be like
Hank Greenway and it would be somewhere
in Missoula like somewhere in downtown
Missoula like they'd rename 4th Street
Hank Green Street and everyone would be
annoyed and they would continue to call
it 4th Street for the next 40 years but
eventually people would just start
calling it Henry Street would you be
into that not really I feel that I feel
like that's weird I feel like roads
should be named after presidents and in
book characters and birds and trees like
any normal place I don't know I'd be
kind of into it I there's a so there's a
writer a local writer here named Dan
Wakefield it's a great writer and just
been a part of the Indianapolis
literature landscape for like 50 years
and he just had a park named after him
like all that I always drive past Dan
Wakefield Park and I do I would be cool
with that I would be cool with a park
but I would not be cool I'd also be cool
with a school you know that's that's
super cool if you can get a school named
after you you've really done something
very right or very wrong but I don't
know yeah I also wouldn't feel right
about a road because I feel like people
resent roads that are named after people
well I feel people resent roads kind of
like nobody really loves a road you know
like boy this thing that takes me to the
place I want to go is a place in itself
know it's a place that takes you
somewhere and for the most part it's
like sort of falling apart a little bit
rubba Lee and there's always under
construction and it's a bad or no I also
just on the other hand like there would
be children growing up on Hank Green
Street and they like like later in life
when they were thinking about their
childhood they would think about Hank
Green Street the way that you and I
think about our childhood Street which
we're not going to say the name of
because it's involved in both of our
passwords like there's something cool
about like forever being a bunch of
people's password because they grew up
on Hank green Street so their passwords
like Hank green you know 61 dang it it
ruined it I've given people everything
they need now it's not given to by
Twitter our whole our whole lives are
gonna be taken over I I don't know I I
often feel like Pete like and I know
that this is kind of wrong because we
need stories and we need to focus on
like on the people who like we need to
connect through humans but I always feel
weird about like extra recognition being
focused on people unless they are like
sort of truly remarkable I mean even if
they are I'm like all people were
necessary like that like the people that
we choose to name things after our only
representations of the thousands or
millions of people who worked to
accomplish the thing that that person is
getting credit for and that's so true
and I'm like and I know that this is
dumb and I know that it's like a dumb
like way to see the world and I should
and I'm wrong but I uh you know I feel
like recognition like individuals don't
deserve recognition humanity does and I
don't know how to solve that problem and
I don't think it's a real problem I
think I'm just a stick in the mud well I
mean you know they've done a good job of
solving that problem in many communist
countries where they just named
everything after the workers are the
proletariat but then they started you
know doing the animal farm trick of
saying that all all animals are equal
but some are more equal than others and
they started naming stuff Leningrad and
Stalingrad and all that I agree with you
though Hank we should name every street
thousands or millions of people
contributed to this street Street and
then when people need directions they'll
just be like what you do is you turn
left at thousands and millions of people
Street and then right on thousands of
millions of people Street and you'll get
there in no time
that's why I think we should name all
the streets after birds and flowers and
trees John alright that's there I did a
terrible job of answered that question I
feel like such a curmudgeon right now
but I have another girl I think it's
nice I think it's I think you know what
Hank there are not enough hardcore
communists who believe that everybody
should have an equal number of streets
named after them and I appreciate that
you are standing up for that worldview
this question is from Linda who I
totally agree with you by the way I mean
I think you're absolutely right that
it's ridiculous that way we slather
individuals in in praise as if
individuals are the center of the human
story but go up what's the next question
this question is from Linda who asks
dear green brothers I'm in a wonderful
relationship with an amazing guy and
while I love him and his family I harbor
a dark secret I hate his mom's cooking
that would be fine but we eat dinner
with his family at least once a week
where we eat the most flavorless
disgusting food I have ever had I mean
honestly stroganoff should not be orange
I feel like that was too much
information Linda now everyone knows who
you are I know that this is you know I
know that this is a first world problem
if I ever heard one but I just don't
know how much longer I can keep eating
this food should I eat before and then
go up should I eat before I go over will
they notice if I never eat in front of
them can I ask for salt or is that
considered rude boyfriends and
boysenberries Linda it's a hard one
that's uh yeah well you know you know
who had this problem was our mom oh yeah
yeah yeah she did she did like they
can't like they would open the cans and
empty the beats on to the police yeah it
might in my dad's yeah and my mom was
just absolutely horrified by the way
that that my dad's family
cooked I don't think there's any problem
with asking for salt I don't think
that's weird at all I mean I I would
argue it's obviously there's a bunch of
culinary problems in this family but
it's weird not to have salt on the table
as an option like I don't think it's
weird to ask for salt I don't even think
it's weird to ask for like some Tabasco
sauce so that all you taste is hot
instead of having to taste the orange
stroganoff I do you know what I mean
what I'm seeing like is like a
possibility of like an assassin's creed
kind of thing where you've got instead
of like your hidden blade up your sleeve
mm-hmm you've got like a like just a
bottle of Cholula and you're just like
yeah it's like you can screw that in
it's like dribbling out through your
sleeve and then you just like put the
cap back on yeah you could bring your
own cell work that's I I could totally
agree bring your own salt and just palm
it I do think that you have so I got
your pocket your pocket is just full of
salt and you're just like reach it in
there and yeah just like a handful
that's good it's good idea there's
nothing else in your pocket that you
might actually get accidentally getting
your food at all the reason I think you
do have to choke it down or at least try
to choke it down is that somebody has
worked hard to make food for you and I
always feel like in that situation
unless you feel like your health is at
risk
you have to choke it down or at least I
that's the obligation I feel but I have
to say just for the record in case
they're listening my mother-in-law's an
excellent cook and I am very grateful to
her this problem I would never have that
problem yeah I I feel like I then
immediately have to say the same hey
could I are both terrified of our of our
in-laws I know I seriously I I yeah okay
let's actually let's move on Hank let's
move on I love my voice so much and I
don't I don't want to ever make any
trouble
this questions from never never make any
trouble just don't make trouble why you
you know what you are you look in
trouble no trouble no trouble
this question comes from Morvan who asks
dear John and Hank my name is Marvin
don't worry about mispronouncing it you
wouldn't be the first I'm a 17 year old
sixth former from England recently I
received an
additional offer from the University of
Nottingham to study chemical engineering
Hank I don't know what that is but it
sounds very impressive I've never
received an unconditional offer of any
kind except I guess lush lush sent me an
unconditional offer of bath balls but I
felt obligated to mention it on the
podcast so it wasn't that unconditional
naturally I was overjoyed as
unconditional offers are very rare
however as I've been telling more people
my good news more people have been
saying that I have only received an
unconditional offer because I'm a girl
and the universities want more girls to
help with their gender statistics and
engineering I think the noise that Hank
made actually would not be a bad answer
to the question Hank do you want to just
make that noise again yeah I share your
noise feeling I assumed at first that
the offer was because I was just a
strong candidate but now I'm starting to
question every academic achievement I've
made how much truth do you think these
claims have how do I stop
second-guessing myself and reclaim my
confidence how do I maintain the
validity of my achievements going into a
male-dominated course in profession
where my gender will always be the first
thing that people judge me on oh and
just for fun John seems terrible at
pronouncing the names of English towns
so he should try saying mine I live in I
swear to God
this the word appears to be soil whole
oh so wait I sell a home so low so low
solely whole so first of all a home
first off Morgan Morvan congratulations
on escaping Sulli Hall for the
University of Nottingham I mean that's
got to be one of the greatest
achievements in the history of the human
social order it's amazing
that's congratulations you know nothing
about Solihull Jon googling a place
where everyone ends up in the greatness
of great places they have a sport team
names the Sulli hold Moors and they just
they just won against Macclesfield Town
Macclesfield I can actually say that one
they have a soccer team looking at it
I'm I'm on Google Maps now just out you
know it's out it's a suburb of
Birmingham John it has a population of
200,000 which is pretty shocking to me
because I didn't even think there were
200,000 people in England but Hank let's
answer the question I wish that I had a
better answer for you I'm sorry that
that your confidence has been taken away
in this frustrating way but you did
great you deserve this thing and the
fact that anyone's first reaction is I
bet you don't deserve this thing means
that they suck is that okay to say not
in everything yeah no I think they may
not they may not they may not suck but
they are wrong deeply wrong and I am
really I also I share that feeling it's
just really it's distressing why would
you say it out loud like why cuz you're
jealous because you're jealous and you
and you're resentful and you feel like
an opportunity that ought to belong to
you has been taken away from you but
that's just dead wrong it's just dead
dead wrong Morvan like you did not
receive an unconditional offer because
you are a girl you received an
unconditional offer because you are
obviously a very talented student who
the University of Nottingham is going to
be lucky to have and desperately wants
to have and you're gonna be a great
chemical engineering student and you are
gonna I mean on yeah it's you are gonna
have to live in a world in which you're
unfortunately yeah you're gonna be
judged by your gender it's inevitable
and it's part of the world but that's
also part of that's also part of why you
why you deserve this the odds are
stacked against you in so many other
ways you absolutely 100% deserve this
Hank can I tell you something about
Sully hull oh I cannot wait because we
had such a good time in Vienna it's it's
the hometown of Nick Drake who is a
superhero or an actor or a famous
Nick Drake Nick grace Nick Drake Oh
Cardinal like a cardinal Nick Drake was
a amazing singer/songwriter also Craig
Gardner you know Craig Gardner and West
Bromwich Albion yeah he's a football
player
what about will grig you know great Greg
the engineer the inventor of flash
memory nope nope former player for the
franchise for applying its trade in
Milton Keynes you know did you know that
there is a health and dental center in
Solihull called
the Bupa health and dental center
buh-bah that's fun I didn't I didn't but
the point is that more than you rule and
anybody who tells you that you don't
rule because if your gender is just a
jerk face just the worst odds that's
very disappointing to hear I tell you
what John Sullivan has a terrible
looking round about this thing is
terrifying and I never want to go really
wow I can't possibly be as good as
Swindon's round about Swindon's round
about is a round about for the ear edges
in fact every time I talk to people from
Swindon they're always like have you
seen her roundabouts and I'm always like
yeah yeah no I have I've also been to
the train museum so I think they don't
that we should put this women
roundabouts on a t-shirt because it is
impressive like it's a cool thing it's a
hell of a roundabout yeah
no no doubt about it it's great it wow
I'm I just googled Sully heard cycle
nobody knows how to pronounce it that's
the point
rosianna how do you pronounce Sully halt
am I saying it right
she said I'm saying it's sort of right
there's not a ton to do in Sully hole
like one of the the number seven
attraction in the town is a factory tour
called the Land Rover experience where
you get to tour the Land Rover Factory
oh that's pretty cool
I'd do that yeah it's got a nice Park
but it's not it's not a river island
park let's move on because this has not
been a good episode of deer I think I
think we're not gonna have a park dude I
don't let you talk about I'm right now
I'm gonna spend the entire rest of this
episode clicking around the snow hole
roundabout just going around in a circle
on Google Street View it's great it's
beautiful so green and lush actually to
go back to to go back to Emmys question
earlier why do you need to travel
anymore when you can just go to Google
Earth so good now it is getting better
and better they just did an update it's
freaking amazing it is it's like going
to the city I was doing Venice yesterday
and I was like why do we ever need to go
to Venice and also we've got this now
for when Venice doesn't exist anymore in
40 years this is great yeah
well I will say Hank as somebody who's
been to Venice a couple times and had a
total of zero phone it might be better
on Google Streetview I did have one
interesting experience in Venice which
is that I well anyway let's move on
actually I'm not gonna tell that story
right now I'm not in the mood for it I
got a question from Henry and Venice was
the first time I was ever I was ever
struck by ice falling from the sky hmm
so I also went to Venice one time that
was my experience you know the Google
Street View in Venice is more like a
it's more like Google sidewalk and canal
view which is fascinating because you
there's no streets yeah of course hey
did that did the guy with the street
view camera go down this alleyway oh he
did it's pretty good anyway John what
are we doing what's this podcast about
oh I have no idea this question comes
from Megan who writes dear john and hank
i am a 22 year old female who has
recently gotten interested in politics
within the last few years as is expected
with growing up I found that my social
and political views as well as the
issues I'm passionate about have
drastically changed since graduating
high school I was wondering what the
best way to navigate the dating world is
now that things like intersectional
feminism LGBTQ rights and minority
rights are such a strong presence in my
life I don't mind differing political
opinions but I do want to make sure I'm
dating someone who also finds these
things important should I just come out
and ask future partners their feelings
on all these issues first or should I
abide by the never discuss
politics rule thanks in advance for the
most dubious of advice pumpkins and
protests there are no politics rule and
dating like news oh don't don't do that
cuz I think that's a bad thing that is a
bet if that is a rule that is a bad rule
that's about it depends on like I don't
know where you're trying to get out of
this experience but if you're trying to
find somebody who you want to spend time
with maybe you should I mean I don't
think you should be alike so you know
I've got some litmus tests here how do
you feel about these issues
you know I but I think that's like
absolutely you should be on the list of
conversation topics what else is there
to talk about these days oh god it's
kind of true I do think that there are
so I know a couple of married couples
and that wasn't a great sentence
grammatically who have very different
political views from each other and they
share other values they share like a lot
of like deep core values and stuff but I
look at their relationships the way that
like to me it's completely alien I have
no idea how I would navigate that if
that were the case with Sarah and me
because I count on being able to turn to
Sarah and say like can you believe this
s on a pretty regular basis and if I
couldn't do that
it would be really bad for our marriage
if I was like can you believe this s and
she would be like I know it's awesome
that would be a big problem for me like
if I were to give you an example if I
was like you know I just feel like it's
really weird how Vladimir Putin has
become a somewhat popular figure in
American political discourse and if
Sarah responded to that by saying I
don't know you're talking about Vladimir
Putin is awesome like it would be a big
problem for me in our day to day life I
agree with you and but that's not to say
that like there are no things that I
disagree with my wife about in terms of
like how the world should be sure yeah
yeah like this did yeah definitely have
agreements about worldview and about
politics and but like and that's fine
but they're like the you know I think
that any good relationship has to be
based upon some shared values and I
think that like our unlike our belief
about how the world should be which is
kind of what politics is in some ways is
should definitely be on the table for
discussion and that that's a really good
good indicator for what what values
people do have and you have to figure
those things out so that you can have
good and productive relationships with
people and if you think that you have to
compromise that in order to have a good
relationship you don't and you shouldn't
I agree
although have you ever voted knowingly
for a different like candidate then
Katharine voted for I don't know if you
guys discuss your votes but Sarah and I
do and we have voted on a couple of
occasions for different candidates and
this whatever whenever we have I have
always been proven wrong by time and
then I have to endure a certain amount
of I can't believe you voted for this
jackass for governor sort of things yeah
I mean carefully Shay there because
because now people know that you voted
for a certain jackass for governor well
I mean at some point in the last twenty
years they don't know which jackass Hank
I lived in Illinois for a while they had
a blood and had a string of Jackass
governors I've lived in Indiana for the
last ten years we've had some we've had
some good governors we've had some
really poor governors one of whom is now
serving in a different office so yeah I
don't know exactly
I don't you didn't you didn't vote for
that jackass governor I don't I did not
vote province no no but yeah but it in
in the case of me and Katherine it's
always been like local offices and it
generally turns out that like for you
know for like you know the Comptroller
of Missoula County the one person is
gonna be better but not
much better that it's gonna be a huge
problem for anyone it's true it's true
which reminds me actually Hank that
today's podcast is brought to you by
sharing values with your partner sharing
values with your partner it's not
something that you can really buy and
sell so it's not heavily marketed but it
is valuable this podcast is also brought
to you by the technical definition of
superhero the technical definition of
superheroes it's available on if you
searched on a search engine and then
you're like okay yeah I guess Batman
doesn't can most importantly this
podcast is brought to you by Austria
Austria or possibly another country with
universal health care now offering visas
to third-rate podcasters hopefully
that's up so I mean this is we have hit
upon something John and if we can't
figure out how to monetize it then we
are failures and it's lastly this
podcast is brought to you by
intercontinental barge travel get
yourself a little room on a working
vessel and which people will be like why
did you make this peculiar and bad
decision all right Hank it's been quite
it's been quite a journey with you we
tried to answer a question about islands
we visited both the Tooting and Sully
hole England it's been it's been it's
been an adventure let's answer another
question and then get to the
all-important news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon the stuff that people really
come to this pod for all right John this
last question comes from Elaine who asks
dear Hank and John I work in a library
as an intern and a huge part of my job
as alpha alphabetizing authors in order
for them to be shelved I was doing
Saturday and I got to thinking who came
up with the order of the alphabet there
any particular reason that a is first
and Z is last etc I can somewhat
understand that we need a specific order
of the alphabet
somewhat you're a librarian you
obviously need to you need that but I
cannot fathom how they decided what
letter is covered what order any answers
dubious or not would be appreciated
memento mori Elaine nobody knows
yeah I mean this is the second question
that we are answering today that we have
discussed previously in a vlogbrothers
video which makes me think we have made
too many vlogbrothers videos but I made
a video about this called why is the
alphabet in alphabetical order and the
answer is nobody knows and in fact the
weird thing about this is that the
alphabet has been in alphabetical order
for longer than any individual word has
existed yeah also that the alphabet has
sort of been in alphabetical order since
before it was the alphabet like since
before it was the English alphabet so oh
yeah
nobody knows before for longer than
English has existed for longer than any
language currently existing on earth has
existed yeah that's weird
what a cool like weird thing and it's
like somebody did that yeah it kind of
points to the possibility and this is
something that I think about a lot and
that really makes my head hurt but
there's a relationship between thought
and language that is so deep and
profound that you really kind of can't
separate the two of them like thought
without language is very different it
looks very different it feels very
different I think and the few people
that we've you know it encountered who
don't have language and who later
acquire in in adulthood talk about
thought differently and it's just weird
and overwhelming and I'm just grateful
for the alphabet yeah well I mean to me
it it's uh it's an indicative of the
great lineage of of humanity like these
are things that that continue and that
progress and that like you know they're
just a useful tool and they were useful
every single generation for you know
since language existed and so we have
continued to use that tool and had no
reason to refine it and so we still have
this this tool that is the order that
that the letters come in that stretches
back pretty much you know farther back
than we can see and and whoever did that
you know whatever group of people did
that they had a tremendous impact on you
know humanity over the years and
we will never know who they were or what
they were thinking and that's fine and
great yeah it's also why we need to name
every street thousands and millions of
people Street Hank before we get we got
a couple Corrections before we get to
the news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon
first off we've talked a lot of smack
about Russia on this podcast apparently
and Natalia wrote in to say dear green
brothers you've probably heard about the
mass protests that happened all over
Russia last week my family and I live in
Russia and our strong supporters of the
Russian opposition and I've always been
frustrated with the fact that people
outside of Russia often judged the whole
country by its leader I'm not saying
that no one in Russia supports Putin and
despises the liberal values that most
people in the u.s. believed to be
essential like freedom of speech I'm not
sure that most people believe that would
be essential in the Tahlia but your
point is well-taken but there are people
like me and my friends that desperately
won't change and spend a lot of time
trying to make it happen I see so much
surpriser the fact that there were mass
protests in Russia yet hundreds of
people have been doing so much in the
last couple of years
I just wanted and she signed off I
really want to be freed Natalia and I
just wanted to underscore that because
it's very easy to imagine countries
monolithically and it is a mistake and
the people who are fighting for a freer
Russia are doing so in at great risk to
themselves and to their families and and
they are real heroes in a way that I
cannot imagine so I just wanted to read
that and then I also wanted to have a
couple quick Corrections Hank most
importantly from Austin you want to read
this one all right yeah I mean seems
seems dubious to me but I am gonna read
it it's a bit of a shift from the last
correction yeah John John just
highlighted one word on this list and it
made me laugh so anyway yeah in a recent
podcast a quote sponsor told the
listeners to pee anywhere except in a
toilet my correction is please don't I
have a very close friend who have made
the terrible mistake of peeing on a
bonfire they felt safe being several
feet back however the intense flames
superheated his urine
dream and burned the inside of his
urethra yeah that does seem a little
dubious I don't know how that would
happen yeah it's I don't think that it's
it's not that good of a conductor of of
heat just a stream of pee well I don't
think would be but I can see getting a
burn I can see like the steam flashing
back and getting a burn around that area
but I have a hard time seeing how the
pee is gonna get so hot to burn the
inside of the urethra but I'm not saying
you Ralston did you go to come over this
friend or is this a story that your
friend told you because my feeling is
maybe like unless you were in the
hospital room where the diagnosis
occurred I think that there may have
been a little bit of exaggeration in
this story and I say that as somebody
who's pretty experienced in the field of
exaggerating stories I do want to say
that there are lots of dangerous places
to pee where you shouldn't pee for
example we were just in Amsterdam where
a number of men are found dead in canals
every year yeah and the vast majority of
them have their flies down because they
were peeing into the canal yep and then
they fell in and the canals have sheer
walls that are very hard to climb out of
yeah don't get drunken tea in a canal
yes that's a great it's just that there
is a murderer who was going around
unzipping people's flies and then
pushing them into the canals it's a
really good that's a really good premise
for a mystery novel but I suspect that
do you want to know what the title of
that novel is John desperate because is
it called
but you're a horse as a throwback to a
very old episode of the pad yeah no John
this was not my joke but I can't
remember who made this joke yeah but it
was made on on the canal in Amsterdam at
vidcon Jack the zipper but we're talking
about okay it's time to get to the news
from Mars and AFC Wimbledon let's start
with the news from AFC Wimbledon hanck
AFC Wimbledon have gone on an amazing
amazing run and by amazing amazing run
I mean they have not scored in one two
three four games they have that scored
zero goals in four games not exciting
their last two games against
Peterborough and Swindon Town were both
nil nil draws which is very impressive
in one sense we haven't kept that many
clean sheets this year but a slightly
less impressive in the sense that you
know we haven't scored in mmm
360 minutes of football which is a lot
even for soccer even for soccer that's
not enough goals yeah that sounds like a
lot of sitting around for this well I
mean you know the only question at this
point is will the Wombles somehow finish
above the franchise currently applying
its trade in Milton Keynes in the in the
end of season table currently kind of
we're down by two points with two games
to play two games left on the season so
it's possible but there is no chance of
being relegated Wimbledon are now
mathematically on relegate able and that
in and of itself is a massive success
for this season being getting promoted
to Ligue 1 this year and being able to
stay in Ligue 1 is awesome so it's been
a successful season even if the last
four games have featured zero goals
well John some folks at Purdue
University have created a device and the
point of the goal of this device is to
basically have a small-scale simple food
processing system that can take things
like soybeans or other or grains and and
make it into food more like food than
just the soybeans so like you take
soybeans and we make a lot of stuff out
of it but we usually need very
large-scale equipment to do that to like
make soybean oil from soybeans and then
take whatever the prot like and result
of that is and then you take all that
stuff that isn't the soybean oil and you
make stuff out of that so this is all
very important if you're thinking about
how to like set up a group of people to
survive on another planet for a
substantial amount of time it's ideal if
they could be taking raw materials and
creating foodstuffs that aren't just
those raw materials and so these Purdue
University scientists made this thing
that separates the stuff using like heat
and and vacuum and etc a bunch of
different techniques separates oils from
grains or from soybeans or other things
and and and creates stuff that can be
then used for the manufacture of other
kinds of food now they did this and it's
sort of like a first test of the kind of
thing that it would need to like that
that NASA would need it's a it's too big
it's too heavy
but it's it's definitely the first thing
of its kind it's it's I would say that
like the basically the size of a
microwave oven which is much smaller
than how you would normally be like the
kind of equipment you would normally
need to do this kind of stuff it's not
this shape of a microwave oven it looks
for all intents purposes like a like a
piece of a lawnmower but but it turns
out that this technology is also very
useful in places where we are still
doing a lot of manual labor and when I
say we I mean humans in order to convert
food into things that can actually be
eaten so you might grow stuff and then
you like have to slam it together and
then boil it to make a porridge that's
actually edible and that's a lot of like
a lot of labor goes into that and in
places where places where like you know
you now live in a city but still you're
in in like somewhere in the developing
world you don't have time to do all that
labor to get your food ready to eat and
so often times people then purchase food
that has gone through an industrial you
know alteration somewhere far away and
then has to be shipped back so that food
might have started out in the country
where you are going all the way to
another country and then come back
processed and then you have to pay for
all of that and so there's there's
they're realizing now that they could be
using this kind of technology to have
smaller scale distributed food
processing that was designed originally
for NASA and for Mars but could
we be used to help people turn the food
that they grow in the place where it's
grown into the kind of foodstuffs that
people would want to consume and and
help in like enliven those economies and
also free up some time that people would
otherwise be using to prepare their food
which i thought was pretty cool yeah and
you know that's happening in my home
state of Indiana that's great to hear
it's nice and you know by the way you
know the president of Purdue University
is no idea former Indiana governor mitch
what's his name mitch Daniels mitch
Daniels there you go so just a little
bit of information for you that's all
being headed up by Mitch the the
billboards for him always said my man
Mitch which I just thought thanks thanks
man
Indiana but yeah Thank You Mitch for
providing more food possibly to the
world and certainly to the future people
on Mars Hank what did we learn today
John we learned that there is no no
politics rule when it comes to that
swiping dating thing that the kids are
doing these days we learned of course
that there is a place in England called
Tooting we learned that Danube Island is
a recreational paradise without the
largest outdoor trampolining available
on planet Earth and of course we learned
that if you really cannot stand your
mother-in-laws cooking just hide a
couple salt packets in your palm I don't
get really good at magic and then use
your magic skills to salt your who's the
first step one and most dear Hank and
John answers get really good at magic
that's such good advice saying it's so
important as step one always get good at
magic Hank thank you for parting with me
we are now gonna make this week in
Ryan's our new podcast which is
available at our patreon it's like a
five to ten minute bit where we talk
about Orion every week if you go to
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John you
can find out more and get a free
information on lots of
various things related to the pod but
thanks for potting with me you can email
us at Hank and John at gmail.com that's
the place to send questions and dear
Hank and John is produced by rosianna
halse rojas and shared and Gibson is
this what you were gonna do John yeah do
that our editor is Nicholas Jenkins
Victoria van Giorno is our head of
community and communications and our
music is by the great gunnarolla and as
they say in our hometown don't forget to
be awesome
I didn't I didn't kill that one but to
be fair you didn't do very well on the
intro
[Applause]
[Music]